it's getting hard to keep track of all
the things that are racist these days
Jefferson statues milk not wanting
african-americans to abort their
children that's racist now add another
one to the long list cauliflower is
racist in a video posted on Sunday young
pioneer Alexandria Kazuya Cortez
explained to her followers that it is
deeply problematic to grow cauliflower
in urban gardens really think about it
when someone says that it's too hard to
do a green space that grows you got
instead of I don't know cauliflower or
something it you're what you're doing is
that you're taking a colonial approval
environmentalism and that is why a lot
of communities of color get resistant to
certain environmentalist movement
because they come with a colonial
colonial lens on that for the fact she's
dumb which she obviously is it's still
confusing what is she saying
we need the liberal Sherpa help us
figure it out Kathy rue is the founder
of Catalina magazine and a frequent
guest on our show and she joins this
night Kathy thanks so much for coming on
so thanks for happy how racist is
cauliflower and let me just say I don't
like cauliflower so don't look at me
like I'm part of the cauliflower problem
or not but how racist is it thank
goodness
well it's part of mono cropping so our
colonial ancestors grew cauliflower so
they're cropping the same-old same-old
vegetables not good for the environment
because it's the same nutrients in the
ground and it actually hurts the
environment to have the same old same
old so the corn the cauliflower is
colonialism so she's talking about
diversifying our vegetables as we should
diversify our culture so you got instead
of cauliflower is the way to go if you
do not want to be racist when it comes
to our community gardens
so okay cauliflower I mean it's you make
a fair point cauliflower is a European
vegetable it originates in the
Mediterranean region I believe
indigenous to the new world is tobacco
that comes from the indigenous peoples
of the Americas and is syphilis too by
the way
so would you say the tobacco it's better
well I don't know now I mean tobacco is
an indigenous plant but you're saying
it's bad but it's I don't understand
you're saying tobacco is worse than
cauliflower are better than cauliflower
well the point is it the the term is the
mono cropping it's the growing the same
thing in our earth so there are no
nutrients that are being new given to
our land so therefore it hurts the
environment so if we grow new things so
forget the tobacco forget the
cauliflower we need the new yuca we need
the new pretty Hannes we knew the new
different plantains
we need different crops being grown to
help our environment so none of those
they say that the climate the climate
plays a role in this so I don't think
yuca or plantains grow very well in the
climate of say New York City Brooklyn or
Queens right those community gardens are
usually led by people with time on their
hands those upper-class women upper
class members of society who have time
to volunteer not those middle-class
workers yeah yes so it's a racist
cauliflower haters are you concerned
Christian are you concerned about
applying social justice standards to the
food we eat do you think ultimately that
might I don't know drive us insane and
cause food shortages I'm afraid I mean
we need to realize that salsa is more
popular than ketchup so if we were truly
racist we wouldn't allow salsa in this
country so thank goodness we are such a
wonderful country that I love allows
diverse foods and crops to come into our
country and we can diversify our food
and our crops yeah
if I get mad at the left I think I think
it must be living hell to be a member of
it because you have to remember all the
rules I don't think I could do all it's
baffling to me we're so glad that you're
keeping track though thank you for
joining us thank you thank you